[Musique]
faire une bonne vinaigrette nécessite de
bons ingrédients mais surtout une bonne
technique
saviez vous qu'il ya aussi beaucoup de
science derrière tout cela
donc on va faire une vinaigrette de bas
en fait ça va être content isabelle
plante et chef et à sa façon chimiste
culinaire assaisonner les salades et
légumes et moi je m'en sert à donner des
poissons d'état n'est qu'une viande par
exemple pour apporter un stick pour que
la vinaigrette
or bien la salade il faut créer un
mélange chimiquement stable entre
l'huile et indique id habituellement du
vinaigre ou du jus de citron
en fait c'est facile c'est une part des
110 siens pour 3par d'huile je trouve
nantes à colas et ça donne une bonne
vinaigrette une bonne base on le devine
et guay à menzel le faire parce qu'une
fois qu'on va avoir acheté l'huile
laissée aux puces du soudan la
vinaigrette huile moi je la joue tout le
temps fier comme ça va donner une
stabilité à l'avenir est vous l'avez
sûrement déjà observé huiles et
vinaigres on peut d'attendre au chu pour
qu'ils se mélange il faut sortir le
fouet les coups de fouets vienne séparer
l'huile en petites gouttelettes qui se
dispersent dans le vinaigre
mais après un certain temps lui ils se
disent aussi du vinaigre à - d'ajouter
un émulsifiant karmani musiciens ou un
ep 5 comme la crème même fromage de
chèvre ça peut servir aussi à épaisseur
de vinaigre mais ça va mieux enrobé
cette salade ça va mieux la farine soit
une plus belle texture aussi clémente à
savoir faire un musicien et un numéro un
on en est tous dans notre frigo sinon
c'est à nouveau avec une vinaigrette un
peu plus complexes comme la césar ou aux
puces de type maya nice metz avec le
jaune 2 qui va servir des musiciens les
émulsifiants sont des molécules avec une
partie qui aiment l'eau et une partie
qui aiment l'huile il réussissait si
l'exploit de réunir 8
vinaigre et de faire en sorte que la
vinaigrette ne se sépare pas et il plein
d'autres passent timité voulait faire
une vinaigrette vega mais on peut y
aller avec du tofu soyeux
ça me missionné votre vinaigrette jamais
racheté du miel ou même le sirop
d'érable aussi puis le mielleux sur les
avancées que le site au pied des ae
pincer l'avenir je commence à tomber les
aromates le hyaric en veut plus encore
le stade est finie on peut dire que les
airs vous étiez c'est un peu limite a
pas trop de sous ça se conserve
facilement de quoi banquette semaine au
frigo un impôt masson impôts hermétique
toutefois la conservation d'une
vinaigrette à base d'oeuf et de trois
jours
c'est le cas de la vinaigrette césar qui
contient aussi jus de citron huile
d'olive ail anchois câpres et parmesan
[Musique]
beaucoup on veut pas que tu as bien dans
notre salle années passent tout d'abord
un fonds enrobé la salade pôle à l'autre
et à kehl et 2 cuillères à soupe pour
une salle d'accompagnement par personne
ou en plus minces us à venir est en fait
le secret c'est elle ajouté toujours
juste avant de servir le club parce que
ça va faire cuire la sinusite et vos fer
cuivre admettons les feuilles de salades
ou les légumes parce qu'on veut pas on
le voit donc on va tout y est la sallaz
va avoir tendance à s'affaisser
la chef nous dévoile ses autres conseils
pour une vinaigrette réussi mais la
forte avance même une heure d'avancé
mais des herbes et les épices
ça va on l'attend de se développer dans
l'huile et ça va donner vinaigrée encore
plus goûteuse
moi je trucs pour eux aussi l'avenir est
quand vous la maîtrise sur votre salaire
c'est toujours d'ajouter c'est le poids
ceci quand même désolant la vinaigrette
mes 15 ans maintenant assad d'avoir
enrichir le goût et la vignette la
beauté des vinaigrettes c'est qu'une
fois les principes chimiques de base
respecter elle se décline à l'infini
quand je m'incline église il que didier
sénac c'est de respecter les ratios oui
puis elle avec notre goût si on est
obligé est ouverte au moins assez dans
mes moyens
plus on ne met plus c'est tout sinon
quelle façon on peut y aller avec ce
même groupe
[Musique]